we want descendants three and we want it
now but unfortunately we'll have to wait
just like everyone else in the meantime
though we can always revisit some of the
best moments The Descendants franchise
has to offer we've pieced together a
timeline that explains everything that's
happened since the first season it's
movie hit the small screen in 2015 so
watch until the end to get hypes for the
upcoming threequel if I ask you
something is it tells me thank you
where's my cell phone
once upon a time villains roams freely
causing mischief wherever they went one
fateful day beasts married Belle and
succeeded in uniting the kingdoms they
became the king and queen of the United
States of auradon and their first decree
was simple banish all villains to the
Isle of the Lost
villains sidekicks and those with wicked
hearts were rounded up and brought to
the Isle the magical barrier was set up
keeping the villains from escaping their
new home the villains were forced to
live a life without magic pleasantries
or freedom 20 long years came and went
and the most atrocious villains had
children of their own they were raised
to be rotten to the core yet somehow
they still managed to disappoint their
parents this is where their story begins
around this time Prince Ben is preparing
to take over his father's throne and
he's made a proclamation of his own for
BK's will have the opportunity to attend
our don prep the decree is made official
and states that mal daughter of
Maleficent Evie daughter of the Evil
Queen J said of Jafar and Carlos son of
Cruella De Vil will be given a chance at
a brand-new life the Vijay's parents
informed them that they've been chosen
to attend our Adhan prep Maleficent
stresses the importance of stealing the
fairy godmothers wand and destroying the
barrier the young villains have the
weight of the world on their shoulders a
glorious limousine boards the Isle and
brings the BK's to our Don they go
through the barrier for the first time
in eights plenty of sweets despite all
the fun they're having they're
determined to make their parents proud
fairy godmother Prince Ben and his
girlfriend Audrey greet the new students
at the gate the V K's are so cool calm
and collected Ben falls for mal in a
flash but she's not thinking about love
she's thinking about glory the V K's
band together and use
he's magic mirror to locate the wand
they sneak out past curfew find the
museum and get the guard to prick his
finger on Sleeping Beauty's spinning
will once inside the museum the BK's are
shocked to see their parents
achievements displayed all around them
Mao shows off her soft side by singing
evil like me it's here that we learned
that she's not as evil as she pretends
to be the gang trips the alarm and makes
a run for its leaving the wands behind
the vee case continue to attend classes
and start enjoying themselves Jay tries
out for the tourney team and makes the
cut he's learning how to be part of a
team instead of solely thinking of
himself meanwhile mal is set on
destroying the barrier she finds out
that Jane is fairy godmothers daughter
and corners her in the bathroom she uses
magic to give her beautiful hair and
manipulates her into thinking that she
isn't pretty across the campus Carlos is
being chased by dude the dog Prince ven
follows him into the forest and helps
him realize that dogs aren't evil
[Music]
Carlos learns that his mother had lied
to him about dogs to scare him into
submission that day in chemistry class
Evie also realizes that her mother's a
liar she finds out that beauty isn't
more important than brains she uses her
magic mirror to cheat in class and ends
up having to do Ted Charming's homework
the V Ches are having trouble getting
close to fairy godmothers wand Mao tries
to come up with a plan but Evie has it
all down pat he tells them that fairy
godmothers wand will be at Ben's
coronation mal finds out that only King
Beast Queen Bella Prince Ben and his
girlfriend Audrey will be allowed to
stand next to the wand mal decides to
become Ben's girlfriend in order to be
within arm's reach of the wand she makes
a love potion and bakes it into a
chocolate chip cookie
moments before mal gives Ben the love
potion Jay expresses his doubts it's
clear that he's enjoying his time at
auradon but mouths on a mission now
tricks Ben into taking a bite of the
cookie and waits for the potion to work
its magic a few minutes later the
students of Aragon gather around the
torn e field Jay becomes a team player
and helps his team win the game the love
potion kicks in after the last goal and
Ben declares his love for mal in front
of everybody back
chemistry class Eevee finds out that
Chad told the teacher about the magic
mirror he wants her expelled but Doug
comes to the rescue
they come to an agreement if Eevee can
pass the test she won't be expelled
Eevee passes with a B+ and takes a
liking to Doug Malin Ben go in their
first date and sparks fly then jumps
into the lake while mal sings if only
she doesn't want to be evil but has no
choice mal jumps into the lake to save
Ben despite not knowing how to swim a
few days later during family day a fight
breaks loose between the vks Audrey her
grandmother and shad malli Vijay and
Carlos realize that they aren't truly
welcome in auradon this fuels mouths
fire and makes her excited for
coronation day the following day Malin
Ben make their way to the coronation
Hall since mal has genuine feelings for
Ben she doesn't want him to be in love
with her forever
so she bakes him an antidote and asks
him to eat it after the coronation
however Ben immediately takes a bite
breaking the spell or so mal was led to
believe
turns out the love spell washed away
when Ben took a dip in the enchanted
lake but he never needed a love potion
to fall in love with mal mal evey Carlos
and Jay are having second thoughts they
don't want to return to the Isles but
the coronation is televised and everyone
back home is watching moments later the
unexpected happens Jane takes her
mother's wand and loses control over it
she makes a hole in the Isles barrier by
mistake that's when Mau grabs the wand
out of Jane's hands with the wand in her
hands now can destroy the barrier and
lets her people run free but she just
doesn't want to anymore love has changed
her then tells now that he chooses to
listen to his heart and she decides to
do the same the V case choose to be good
once and for all
that's when Maleficent shows up she
ridicules her daughter for having
feelings and freezes time Maleficent
turns into a dragon and chases the V
Ches around the hall only to be turned
into a lizard by mal everyone celebrates
and venez crowns king but that's not the
end of the story
descendants - six months go by without
incidents mal is learning how to be a
woman of the court she's become famous
due to her relationship with king ven
but something's amiss now dreams of
being wicked
and mrs. who she used to be EVR jizz Mao
to donate her spell book to the museum
while sewing her cotillion dress it's
yellow and blue and unlike anything Mao
has ever worn now has become Little Miss
Perfect and she hates it a lot has
changed in six months Evy owns a
clothing business J's the big dog on
campus Carlos is in love with Jane and
Audrey is nowhere to be found
Doug and Evie have put a lot of money
into creating Evie's four hearts and
soon enough Evie will be able to afford
a castle of her own minutes later we
find out that King Ben is having a
stained glass display commissioned to
show mal just how much he loves her but
just in case she didn't know he also
buys her a purple scooter then notices
that mouse spell book is in her locker
and urges her to donate it to the museum
meanwhile Jay becomes a captain of our
Don swords and shields team he fights
against Lonny
daughter of Mulan and wants to give her
a spot on the team but Chad reminds him
that girls aren't welcomed for the past
six months Carlos has been trying to get
out of the friendzone he's too nervous
to ask Jane to the cotillion
so he gets mal to make him a truth gummy
unfortunately dude the dog gobbles it up
and gains the ability to speak ever
since Ben's coronation mal and Ben have
had little time to themselves so Mau
whisks been away on a magical date she
enchants a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich causing it to look and tastes
like mrs. Potts best dishes problem is
then students find out the entire picnic
is a lie Finn tells now that our Don
isn't like the Isle of the Lost
and mal storms off after six months of
trying to fit in and coming up short Mau
decides to return to her roots she
enchants her scooter and journeys back
to the Isle once back home mal visits
curl up and die the adorable dizzy
Tremaine gives mal a gorgeous makeover
soon after Harry hook walks in and finds
out that mal is back he runs off to tell
Emma the news King Ben evj and Carlos go
to the Isle to bring mal home but she's
not having any of it she breaks up with
Ben for good and is convinced that it's
for the best
moments later King Ben gets kidnapped by
Harry and his ghouls he tells Jay Carlos
and Evie that uma has been and wants to
meet with mal by sundown now goes to
Ursula's fish and chips to chat with
they obviously don't like each other now
loses an arm wrestling match and is
forced to retrieve fairy godmothers wand
in exchange for Ben while mal and Evie
had to curl up and die to make colourful
smoke weapons Jay and Carlos go back to
auradon they used their 3d printer to
make a fake wand and return to the Isle
but this time Bonnie and dude tag along
meanwhile uma and King ven get to know
each other then finds out that he made a
mistake by leaving the other BK's behind
he tells Emma that he wants to work with
her and give other vkz a chance at
redemption
unfortunately uma isn't convinced the V
Ches arrived just in time to make the
trade now points the wand at dude and
makes him talk proving that the wand is
legit even though it's fake dog just to
make me look fat they tricked Emma and
start throwing colour bombs onto her
ship Lani Carlos Jay Ben mal and DV
fights like their lives depend on it
they escaped from the Isle making umma
more furious than ever before
once home everyone starts preparing for
the cotillion Carlos finally mustered up
the courage to ask Jane and she accepts
Lonnie becomes the captain of the swords
and shields team Chad receives a
distress call from Audrey and ditches
the cotillion to rescue her while
waiting for King been to arrive his
parents tell mal how much they liked her
and how happy they are for their son
seconds later King Ben makes his grand
appearance but there's a twist
uma is attached to his arm and they're
happy as can be
Ben thanks now for breaking up with him
because it led to Emma seconds before
the BK's leave the cotillion King Ben's
glass display is showcased for all to
see that's when Mao realizes that Ben
truly loves her for who she is
uma tries to convince fairy godmother to
take down the barrier but she refuses
that's when Mao kisses ven and breaks
uma spell Ben tries to convince her that
she's done nothing wrong and that they
can work together to create a better
world still uma jumps into the ocean and
transforms into a gigantic octopus / sea
witch that's when Mao transforms into a
dragon for the first time uma and mal
face off in the water
King Ben dives into the ocean to break
up the fight he tells them
his wise words cause uma to swim back to
the Isle and Arden celebrates its latest
victory but not before Mau gives fairy
godmother her spell book once and for
all
evn King then worked together to bring
more BK's to our Adan and dizzy received
a royal invitation right before the
movie ends
uma shows herself once more under the
sea a descendent story Mau tells dizzy
that a great danger is coming for Adan a
war is brewing and bad things are coming
and while many of us think OMA is behind
this others aren't so sure before you go
let us know who your favorite
descendants character is in the comments
below and while you're at it tell us all
your favorite OTP and that's a wrap
make sure to give this video a big
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
to the things thanks for watching we'll
catch you next time descendants fans
[Music]